[Music]
okay so huh let's see what do we got
here we got
charles and sandra eric and lee
and presumably other people watching so
and got a hundred people here today
all right okay well thank you for
joining us
i'm always a little bit nervous with all
this technology and stuff
anyway we won't go into the details but
uh there was a two-step process to join
the zoom conference i must have been in
the wrong one at any rate
uh you know why do we do these 90-day
challenges all right uh i i think anyone
who is using link regularly is motivated
but it helps us when we have a very
specific goal
you know
uh
if if we're walking the dog and we throw
a ball out in the field the ball's gonna
the dog is gonna chase after that ball
it just motivates the dog he's happy
walking along
at a leisurely pace but when you throw a
ball out there the dog gets really keen
to chase down that ball
and i find it's the same with me now i'm
quite keen now with my arabic i've kind
of been
kind of going along with arabic and
persian i did some
some turkish by you know along the way
and
and i i kind of feel that i'm not
getting to where i want to get to as
fast as i want to get there
and so i said you know what i should
really focus on my arabic leave aside
the persian as much as i like persian i
like turkish there's all kinds of things
i like but i have to put those aside and
really focus in
on arabic
and and so i look at my goals in two
ways i look at my goals in terms of what
i want to be able to do in the language
and then i look at specific goals
in terms of the statistics on link so
i'll first talk about the sort of
general goals and then i'll show you my
specific goals showing you my profile on
link
and and i should say that the reason we
have all these statistics on link is for
that reason very often in learning
languages it's easy to have the feeling
we're not getting anywhere
or we're putting all this work in and
still don't understand the same things
or still have the same difficulty saying
things
so there's that perception and this is
particularly like
in the first three months or in the
beginning we have this feeling that you
know something that we didn't understand
at all we now understand to some extent
we're able to say a few things and so we
have a great sense of achievement wow
look at me you know five months ago i
didn't understand the thing and now i
understand something so that the the
achievement is quite clear
but then we entered that what's known as
the plateau which is that long long long
period
and the reason is very simple and that
is that
the the high frequency
words are just that very high frequency
and they show up all the time so they
show up so often that we kind of get
some of them so we get that high
frequency vocabulary but but frequency
declines very very quickly in in every
language
uh and there's all kinds of studies that
show this
and even if you go to a specific domain
like science or music or whatever it is
the frequency declines very very quickly
so pretty soon we're dealing with
trying to learn a language where the
words that we want to learn
may show up
you know if it were a book it might show
up once every 30 pages
and yet we still need that word and
words like that
we need them in order to understand
meaningful content content content
that's meaningful to us
so in my case
i want to understand these arabic
podcasts from al jazeera
now i know al jazeera is owned by the
qatari government and as propaganda i
don't care whether it's propaganda or
not it talks about subjects that are
interesting it talks about
nuclear power in the gulf it talks about
you know israel-palestine it talks about
all kinds of stuff from a perspective
which i may or may not agree with and it
uses all of that vocabulary
and so i'm there listening to it and
without reading it i understand
you know i pick out words
and in fact sometimes i pick out many
many words but it doesn't come in as
meaning it comes in as words
and i want to get to the point where i
just
and of course so i should first enter so
then i'll get the text and i'll read it
and i'll look up words and gradually get
a better sense of what's there and then
i listen to it again and i get a better
sense but it's still not
just plain meaning it's it's words
and i want to get to where i can because
i'm subscribed to this podcast
uh without even having to go to a
transcript on link i pick up two or
three uh podcasts in the morning
and i listen to them and i and there's
80 meaning there that's my goal i want
to get to that point because then i can
really enjoy
kind of getting the language in me and
it's not as much work so
and because i don't have a lot of people
here in vancouver that i can speak to in
arabic
yeah i'd like to speak better and i will
during this period i will speak more
often
and i will improve my listening improves
my speaking but my main goal at this
stage is to understand these podcasts if
i can do that if i have good
comprehension on these podcasts
the speaking will take care of itself i
just have to speak more
and then i'll speak better so that's my
specific goal in these 90 days i want to
get to a point where i can understand
instead of say 20
of these podcasts i want to understand
60
occasionally 100 of these stretches
where i understand crystal clear what
they're saying and then of course i lose
it because there's too many words i
don't know but i want to get to that
stage now let's see if i can
share
my screen because
i haven't done this before with this
technology
so let's see what happens here bear with
me so share screen
uh
hmm so i only have the one screen
usually i have two
so i'm gonna go to my desktop
and then try and move to um so zoom
let's move this guy out of the way here
and link learn languages
hopefully maybe mark you can give me a
signal oh
okay you are sharing screen you can see
my screen
yes yes okay super yeah all right
all right it works i'm always amazed
when this technology works
usually when it doesn't work is because
i'm stupid
so
it's comforting to know that i did it
right
so here is my um
you know arabic page here and so latha
is this uh podcast series from al
jazeera
which i have transcribed i have a lady
in morocco who transcribes them
i have written to al jazeera several
times to ask for permission to share
them they never answer i'm inclined to
share them anyway but i don't want to
get in trouble so i don't so this is
strictly for my own use one day if they
ever answer or if we ever get permission
then we'll share them
so if i now go
how do i move these guys okay so if i go
to my profile which is over here my icon
i click on that and i go to profile
there was a way to get this to show up
at the top screen anyway
so
now it all seems to work more slowly
in uh
you know when we're
viewing it together but
so i find this profile it's it's kind of
very interesting so the first thing i
think is worth looking at is
my history with arabic to give you some
background okay
so if we look at say known words
actually one thing i'll show you first
of all
on my statistics
if i look at all time
uh and i think these statistics they're
they could be better perhaps but they're
very useful i find them motivating to go
to
so you'll see here that for whatever
reason
link told me that with the amount of
time that i spent with arabic
i should know twenty thousand words well
i don't i know thirteen thousand six
hundred and thirty eight words
on the other hand
link says
you should have saved or created eleven
thousand links
in fact i haven't i haven't created 50
000 links
so right off the bat this tells me that
i'm going through a lot of stuff
looking up words fighting my way through
this content creating 50 000 links
but most of those links are still
unknown they're still yellow they're
still out there
uh
i'm maybe
step one of ten steps
to getting to where i will know these
words because as we all know from
experience we can see the same word lots
of times and not remember it
so
my immediate goal
is to take these 50 000 links that i've
created and try to convert them into
known words and uh
i would like to get the twenty thousand
dollars uh i know from experience that
twenty thousand known words is still not
enough to a hundred percent understand
these podcasts
uh hopefully i'll get beyond 20 000
words but i want to set you know a
reasonable goal i've been at arabic as
i'll show you shortly for quite a long
time and i'm only at
13 000 known words so i have to
essentially increase my known words by
50 of where i am now
it won't it'll be 60 comprehension it
won't be it won't be much higher than
that but it'll still be significantly
better than i am now
so
uh the links learned i don't worry about
too much those are you know words that
i've moved to known as long as i take
care of
getting these known words the known
words number up and just to clarify
not every known word is a unknown that i
deliberately is a word that i
deliberately learned
many of these because they are related
to words that i already know
they will i just won't look them up
because i know what they are so the the
sort of incidentally learned words it's
quite a large number
not as big in arabic as would be the
case for say an english speaking speaker
learning french
because there are so many words that we
recognize
from another language
that the sort of you know incidentally
acquired vocabulary is much much larger
not the case
with arabic so my goal and the two
principle goals that i'm going to work
on are getting my known words up to 20
thousand
i'm not gonna worry i have more than
enough created links now
i could spend my time
on yeah i showed you that um lava
this arabic podcast series i got i don't
know 30
articles there
i could go back into them
and try to get to those yellow words and
learn them
however
there's something about new
there's something about not going over
stuff that you heard and listened to
before
it's just more appealing to go for new
so i have my uh collaborator there in
morocco my instructions to her are just
pick out two podcasts that you think are
interesting and transcribe them every
week i may move her up to three a week
it's always more interesting to go into
new material that you haven't heard
before it's fresh for the brain
and i will see the yellow words in those
contents some of the yellow words that i
have
in the
content that i've already been over
those yellow words will show up again
so
i will be adding to my
you know
links number but it'll be
incidental my goal is to get to my get
my known words up to 20 000 so that i
can understand
the podcast better now one last thing
before i stop sharing my screen and we
break out into our groups
is just to show you um
so i started arabic first of the three
middle eastern languages
uh if i look at this arabic and i go all
time
you'll see that i've been at it for
quite a while if i just look at known
words i could look at listening i could
look at other indicators
but you'll see that i started back in
january of 2018
but then there were periods where i
didn't do much
and here as well so there's been sort of
peaks and valleys
and um
i think i would like to go for the next
three months to make this a high plateau
of activity
uh and if i you know just to show you
for example if i look at my uh
whatever turkish for example
we will see
that the turkish was all bunched up into
here
and then i haven't done anything and i
decided that i couldn't do arabic
persian and turkish was just simply too
much
so i dropped the turkish but i loved it
and i will go back to it
uh but it took away from my arabic
similarly if i look at my persian
where did it go russian swedish
we got to get more consistent in the
order of these romanian i've lost it
where is that green
red flag oh here we are
so here again you'll see with persian i
had two periods of concentrated activity
into persian so all of this took away
from my arabic
if i had focused only on arabic during
that period i would be further ahead but
i wouldn't have persian and turkish so
you know it's always a matter of choice
so now uh my goal is to focus on arabic
in the 90-day challenge
achieve this higher degree of
comprehension of my podcast which will
necessarily mean that i end up speaking
better
and i will do
several
online discussions in arabic with arabic
tutors through the 90-day period to give
people a sense of how i'm progressing
because my ability to express myself
will be a reflection of how many words
the extent to which i've been become
more familiar with the language okay
stop share
all right so there you have it now uh
i guess eric you take over and
split people into groups
all right um just before i split people
into groups i just wanted to um
hopefully you guys can hear me i
apologize i'm in a cafe um i have one
question that i'd like to ask steve we
have a lot of people today and
unfortunately we'll be able to go
through everyone's questions obviously
but there's a question we got from an
email that i'll read out to steve
and um it should
if your answer should help others so
here we go
um it seems to me that at one point a
key movement is to turn active reading
text hearing podcasts using videos is
fine but doing that for too long or
forever is like staying
being a bird fed by his mother at one
point it is essential to become active
um
it can be for example describing one's
vocation by writing or talking when
doing that you search words that you
need to know that you need now
that you want to say that you want to
use over and over again you start
building your own castle of words
um you reverse this process you walk by
yourself it makes a huge difference and
you start remembering much more easily
steve what do you think of active
learning and when to start
well i mean
the key to successful language learning
is to enjoy the process and to spend the
time
so if you are motivated to keep a diary
if you are motivated to talk to yourself
uh if you can find a circle of friends
to speak to
if you want to get on uh
you know uh skype with a tutor these are
all good things to do
in other words you want to be motivated
you want to do things that are
meaningful to you
and you want to spend enough time
my own view is that in order to speak
well you have to speak a lot
i prefer to delay speaking a lot
until i have enough words so that i can
actually have meaningful conversations
uh i have been in situations where i
don't have much vocabulary i don't
understand what the other person is
saying
on skype or whatever and we just
say the same things over and over again
and so i'm not expanding my
my capability in the language
uh comes a point and i would say that in
my own case with the many stories now
i've started speaking earlier
in the case of check i waited
six seven eight months and i thought
that was early because with russian i
waited more than a year before speaking
but now with the many stories i find
that it kind of
gives me momentum
and after three months i started
speaking in arabic and persian and
turkish and you can see videos on my
youtube channel of me speaking those
languages
so i think it's a matter of personal
preference
uh but don't underestimate the extent to
which input activities prepare you for
speaking
and i have had the experience many times
like i didn't speak to my arabic tutor
for six months but i did a fair amount
of listening and reading and she was
amazed at how well i spoke how much i
had improved in those intervening six
months just through listening and
reading
shelby who
started with link on french and we have
been doing this series
uh and she's just been listening and
reading and she doesn't like the mini
stories like i do i
enjoy the many stories to me it's just
rope like lots of repetition i can do
them it's like listening to a buddhist
mantra
shelby doesn't she is of a different
generation she prefers music songs
and and she found some other interesting
content that would more to her taste but
the point is she spent a lot of time
listening and reading and then we spoke
after
you know it was a 12-week thing and she
was amazing she was amazing so
the listening and reading it's not
purely
passive
uh
what we acquire passively
i don't know if this is relevant but
there is a thing called mirror neurons
and when you hear someone play the piano
for example
the
neurons in the brain activate the same
way as if you were playing the piano
so i'm not a neuroscientist i can't
connect that to the phenomenon of lots
of listening and reading helping you in
your output but it does
however
ultimately
at the time of your choosing you got to
start speaking
and i start with once a week and then i
might move it up to twice a week
it's difficult to get enough speaking
just via the internet to make a big
difference
where you really take off in a language
is you if you have the opportunity
to be with people a lot like you have a
whole evening three four hours you're
with the native speaker you have trouble
you're afraid you're not
speaking quickly enough to stay in the
conversation and you're struggling to
understand
that kind of intense
you know
involvement immersion is what does it
however a couple of times a week via
skype
is also useful so i i think the question
there is not that you become a bird fed
by its mother
you're always in control you can do
whatever you want you can speak to
yourself you can keep a diary you can
connect with people on the internet and
so really it's a matter of what you want
to do
all right great
oh sorry
oh no worries um i just want to let
everyone know um we're going to go into
breakout rooms now these rooms will have
about
i'm sorry eric one thing i want there
were a couple of other questions that i
thought were interesting that were
related and it is about this issue of
you know when is it comprehensible how
much should i listen when do i move on
this comes up all the time
okay so i just want to leave one more
thought before you go to your breakout
rooms
you know how much you understand
when you move on is entirely up to the
learner
i
there is significant research showing
that if you if you stay with one thing
until you understand it 100 that is in
fact very inefficient
the brain likes novelty you are better
off to move on when you understand 50
even 30 percent go to someone something
else that you understand 30 then you can
go back to that first one in other words
this what's known as interleaving don't
try to master stuff
give it a good crack then move on to
something else and something else then
go back to the first this idea that
you're going to master something
master even like a declension table or
get to where you understand 100 of a
particular lesson that's elusive that's
an illusion it's not going to happen
you know it's all input it's all the
language coming at your brain your brain
is starting to form patterns
and so don't be don't stay too long in
one and and the term comprehensible
again obviously when we start nothing is
comprehensible so obviously you progress
from zero comprehensible to a small
percentage but you don't want to stay
with the one thing until it becomes 100
comprehensible because it won't
but if you go 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 nine ten
back to one gradually slowly the lights
start to come on and more and more of it
becomes comprehensible so i hope that's
helpful
hi steve my name is anthony i'm from
peru i'm learning english
i started three months ago to study
english very seriously
now i am trying to speak more frequently
but my goal is not to
[Music]
achieve
how you say
fluency in speaking i want to read
fluently and
i can achieve this because i my my goal
is to read articles about nutrition and
this because i am studying nutrition and
i want to read this and i don't
understand the majority that i enrich
but i try to put all my effort to
understand but maybe i it's because i
don't practice my grammar or maybe it's
because i don't
i don't have enough words
i don't know why did you say you want to
read about nutrition
yes nutrition topics yes yeah
okay first of all you are fluent
okay you speak very comfortably you use
the language correctly
your word order word usage grammar
everything is fine maybe i could find a
mistake if i listen to you again but i
didn't hear any
now when you go into a particular field
could be nutrition it could be nuclear
science it could be sports obviously
there are going to be technical terms
there are going to be
certain phrases that are used often
and if you are not familiar with those
it's going to be difficult it's intense
so you just have to stay with it and
that those are the ideal kind of
contents to import interlink look up
words and phrases
and if you can combine
the sort of content about nutrition if
there is audio available it's easier
because listening is higher resonance it
kind of if you can combine the listening
with the reading even better but even
just plain reading and and reading a lot
on a subject
that you are interested in so that gives
you a big advantage like you're familiar
with the subject you're interested in
the subject if you just keep reading and
listening you will acquire those words
and in terms of your ability to speak
and and your you know grammatical uh you
know you're the accuracy of your
language it's already very very good so
i just think it's a matter of time
patience is the big word in language
nothing happens overnight as as this
manfred spitzer that i often quote
german neuro
scientist he says you know the brain
learns the brain has to learn the brain
is a pattern recognition machine it will
learn the disadvantages the brain learns
slowly um
all right if
everyone can mute themselves and i'll
leave it to steve to conclude the
meeting so i'm just going to turn my
microphone and steve take it away
well the only thing
i would be interested in knowing what
were some of the issues that came up in
the other uh you know breakout sessions
first of all i should say i was a bit
disappointed because i didn't have my
glasses on and i thought it was a
breakfast room
but i got there was a breakout room so
you know i still got to go and grab a
cup of coffee now no
uh
we had some we had discussions about uh
you know uh learning italian if you're
spanish or uh you know tv versus uh
versus uh you know listening and reading
i wonder what were some of the should we
discuss some of the issues that came up
uh in the other groups or should we just
save that for the next session
i think we can save that for the next
session um i would love to see the same
people and more people to join the next
session um we have tons of participants
but if anyone has any questions
you can definitely hit link up on
twitter
and we'll look at that and um of course
we'll be looking into doing something
like this similar so just keep your eyes
on link's social media account for new
updates um and yeah see if you can go
ahead
okay
there are some questions flashing up on
the screen here but i guess we should
deal with those you're saying people
should email or get them to us through
social media and i mean i think we can
spend five minutes answering questions i
mean everybody's here now i i unless
yeah i think there's no so where can i
so should i go to the there's a i have a
chat list here
should i address the questions that are
on that list sure
okay
so
share what you talked about
i haven't signed up for any as it seems
overwhelming to me is there a way to go
step by step so mark you want to answer
that
yeah i mean i think it can feel
overwhelming at first for people because
um
there is a lot happening i i we get that
comment uh uh
not infrequently and we are working on
simplifying the interface and in a new
version
but uh for now
uh first thing is don't don't be afraid
to click around click around on things
and and fundamentally what you're doing
is you're reading and listening
you're clicking on blue words that you
are new to you
you're seeing a bunch of meanings that
other users have used or created
try and find one that fits that context
don't worry it doesn't have to be right
if it turns out that you were wrong
you'll eventually figure that out
big thing in language learning is don't
expect perfection you're not here to
learn it nail it down right now you're
just kind of giving yourself an idea of
what that word means
you'll see it again later and later and
again in future lessons and over time
you'll actually really learn what that
word means but you're clicking on blue
words looking them up
choosing a meaning to make that word
yellow those yellow words are now words
you're trying to learn you'll see them
again in this lesson and subsequent
lessons
over time you'll realize that hey i know
some of these yellow words you'll then
start to move them to known
um
that's the basic flow
once you kind of get used to the basic
flow you can then start exploring some
of the other functionality and and to do
so
click on the
in the corner under your profile there's
a help menu you'll find some useful
resources like our
getting started guide grammar guide link
academy there's videos there's help
questions
um
yeah i think i'll leave it at that but
don't be don't be intimidated by the
interface just click around
hi um i have a question i i wasn't sure
if i could ask or if you wanted to go
through the list i'll go for it
okay um
all right so something that has bothered
me uh for i guess something that has
bothered me regarding learning languages
in general is that i feel as though
if i do not sound like a native speaker
um
i'm never going to achieve success
and or i feel as though i'm always going
to sound like the american
and while i realize that in the united
states because we're from all over you
know people here from all over the world
and they grow up with different families
and stuff like that so we all have
different accents so it's much more
acceptable to have an accent of any type
in america or the united states than it
is say in germany
if you have an accident in german
and when you speak german you stick out
like a sore thumb
um and they say that it's
important that your pronunciation is
good so that you're
fully understood um so that the meaning
comes across you you won't know ten
thousand words that's great but if you
can't pronounce them
you're out of luck so i was wondering
i guess what my question is can you
give me uh
your opinion about pronunciation accents
how not how important that is but
how i guess to strive
for the best accent possible
okay um
first of all
very very very few people who learn
languages as adults
end up sounding like a native
okay
they may be very good the native
pronunciation is our goal it's our model
it's what we imitate
but we just don't get there it's like
it's like me playing golf i'd like to
you know play golf like tiger woods but
i won't but i still enjoy playing golf
and
i mean i have dealt with so many people
around the world japanese swedish german
french spanish
and if we're all speaking english we all
communicate without any difficulty and
they all have an accent and they all
have certain structures that come from
their native language which are not
you know idiomatic they're not correct
in english and it doesn't prevent us
from communicating and you know being
good friends or whatever so it's just to
me is
this idea that you're going to strive to
sound like a native is just not
realistic
i think too i mean i've been in germany
i've been in japan
uh certainly in japan i'm recognized as
not a local
uh and in germany in germany i'm
recognized as not local when i speak and
it doesn't bother me it doesn't bother
them i think we can be
uh
and there's nothing wrong with sounding
like an american or sounding like a
frenchman or sounding like a japanese
because that's what you are
the main thing is who you are how well
you connect with those people
and in terms of the language use
how you use the words how whether you're
able to use the words correctly
most of the time it won't be 100
and if you have a significant vocabulary
now in terms of how to improve your uh
uh pronunciation i think a lot of
listening is important because you can't
pronounce what you can't hear so you've
got to hear it
and you've got to hear not only the
individual pronunciation of the words
but the intonation every language has a
different type of intonation in english
we tend to be a little more sing-songy
than the french for example that are
kind of more monotonous and then the
japanese have a form of intonation so
i think it's quite useful in link if you
listen to a sentence then you take the
the mini stories where they are time
stamped and you can listen to a sentence
you can go through sentence view and
listen to each sentence
spoken by the native speaker and then
try to imitate that intonation even if
you fumble some of the sounds you can't
make a guttural r in german or whatever
it might be doesn't matter get the
intonation and if you get the intonation
right your language is going to sound
very comfortable to the native speaker
so a i don't think it's that big a
problem i think people make too much uh
to do about pronunciation
and b there are things you can do focus
on listening
uh focus on the intonation and then when
you speak don't worry about it
okay all right well thank you so much
for your answer i appreciate it
now should i mark should i go through
some of the questions here that are in
the chat right here
sure
okay so there's this question about 100
you know two things that i see here one
is
learn you know create a hundred things a
day
you'll find out what your comfort level
is given the amount of new material that
you want to go through every day
you may find that 50 links a day is your
comfort level but get some level that
you're prepared to maintain
i found when i gave myself the
ridiculous
goal of 100 links in each of three
languages arabic persian and
turkish i would be there 10 30 at night
preparing to go to bed and grab my book
to read and i say holy cow i'm still
behind in arabic and persian so then i
would have to go and slog my way through
something so that i could create 100
links so that was too much pressure find
something that's comfortable and stay
with it
a hundred for one language i don't think
is unrealistic
it depends on
how much new vocabulary there is in the
material you're going through find
something that's comfortable for you and
stay with it
uh also with regard to uh reading the
mini stories 40 times i don't read the
many stories 40 times
i don't read them more than once when
i'm reading them
i tend to listen a lot again not i don't
sit down and listen to the same story 15
times
but i have 60 mini stories i go to
you know
listen to course audio so i now have a
playlist of 60 mini stores i put it on
shuffle
and get in my car and for the next 30 or
40 minutes i will be listening to a
number of mini stories selected at
random that i've heard before
and every time i discover something new
and keep doing that eventually total
number of times listened becomes 10 20
30 40. so it's not a matter of sort of
block trying to nail down a mini story
it's just that i find these mini stories
quite good in terms of getting a better
feel for the basic structures and the
high frequency verbs in the language but
i certainly don't recommend that you
read the same story same story um you
know 20 times in a row i think the rain
would turn right off
uh we have a guy asking should he set a
target of a hundred
links a day and and uh
you know create a hundred links
go through content until he creates his
hundred links or should he choose a
smaller number
and
try and learn those
i would go for the former
because you want to expose yourself to
the language
and
i believe that the sort of extensive
approach you know pushing yourself into
new content new content that might be
interesting to you you're discovering
new blue words which is also fresh and
new and you will come across your yellow
words anyway
and i think that
is better the brain is more alert doing
that in my experience than trying to
kind of really nail down like go over
this until because you can go through
the same little lesson with those yellow
words in the hope that you know if i go
through it often enough those words will
become known but they won't
you know i just find that that every
effort that i've made and i've done it
many many times to try to nail something
down
ends up being elusive and you're far in
my experience i prefer to push forward
push forward and along the way what do
you know some of these yellow words
disappear and become
okay
[Music]
now here's a question about someone
learning japanese and kanji
yeah
kanji
is for japanese
i find that in order to be able to read
and reading is important to learning you
need a lot of kanji and kanji is the one
example
where
space repetition really works
uh
because you're it's almost like you're
learning sort of
discrete objects
yes it's connected to the meaning within
the context but not to the same extent
that sort of words that you hear so you
do have to put in an effort with the
kanji use a spaced repetition system or
some other system
but combine that with
the benefits of listening and reading on
link
and every time you come across the kanji
and link you can look it up again and
that's also helping to reinforce it but
i think the idea that you take what i
did 50 years ago initially 10 and
eventually 30 kanji a day that i go
through on some sort of a space
repetition basis
and i shuffle them back in because
however you know many if i do
10 and i
the next day i've forgotten half of them
so whatever you do you're going to
forget you have to keep on relearning
relearning relearning and eventually
they stick
okay yeah
how should you use the vocab recap i
guess review i feel overwhelmed by the
number of links
okay
yeah i think that one of the problems
with any kind of a review process spaced
repetition process is just the
the way words that need to be reviewed
just starts to accumulate and pretty
soon you could spend your whole time
reviewing words
which is not where you want to be
it's more fun
to be finding these words in a context
where you're coming across the words on
some basis randomly
but you're also getting used to the
language you're hearing the language
you're reading the language so you're
doing a lot of other things that are
connecting you with the language in a
way that simply reviewing words doesn't
do
so i would personally i ignore like i i
think i showed you my statistics from
arabic i have 50 000 saved links
50 000 save links there's no way i could
go through and review those 50 000 links
and yet and what am i motivated to do i
look forward to my new transcribed
podcast from al jazeera because i want
to get into something new it's that
sentiment of discovery and along the way
the yellow words some of them eventually
become known so i would not be overly
concerned where i use the review a lot
is
first time with an article i might
review the saved links as i turn the
page
so i'm in uh
link i'm going to the next page and i
can review the words that were on that
page and even if i'm not i'm in sentence
view there might be three or four
rather
you know brand new words and just kind
of focus in on those to get a little
better exposure to those new words i'll
review them as i turn the page but i
won't go back into my list of 50 000
words
and try to knock them off
when i say i won't i occasionally do
because it's very often useful to find
words that are alphabetically arranged
because then you start to see four or
five words that have the same root
because they start with the same letter
with the same component so that can
sometimes be helpful as a as a variety
as an activity that's you know different
than simply listening really
okay
but i guess for the most part
don't worry that's a common theme we
hear in our support questions is i'm
overwhelmed by all the links i'm
creating i don't want to create more
that's not that's not the
right approach create more keep creating
links that's the best thing you can do
and every once in a while you can review
some of them if you're doing japanese
and you want to work on certain kanji
you can make lists tag lists of keywords
you want to review but you should not be
you should be creating far more links
than you can possibly review and don't
worry about it
okay i see some requests for irish i
guess
mark the usual answer is if we get 60
mini stories
in irish and if there's a good supply of
other content that we can add to that or
that people can import and if there are
online dictionaries which i'm assuming
there are for irish then we would add it
yeah we've said we've directed people
there there's a contribute page under
the community tab on link so if if
anyone's interested in helping create
irish content or to help get irish or
any other language added
you'll find information on that page
um i guess probably we've been at this
for an hour now it's a good time to to
uh
end things for now we'll we'll do this
again i think it's gone well um
of course any feedback that any of you
have please let us know
we're doing these um to help all of us
understand can i say one thing meet each
other yes i'm just going to say alca was
asking about indian languages we do have
gujarati because somebody volunteered to
produce the many stories in gujarati
that's not the most
widely spoken indian language i think we
have people working on
hindi and volunteers working on hindi
and urdu so again the same rules apply
go to the contribute page and if you can
help us create content in indian
languages we're happy to have it
okay with that we'll uh hope to see you
all next time
thank you happy linking bye
[Music]
you